[Music]
drug dealing was something that was
natural to me
if you would have told us that we were
criminals we would have laughed we're 20
year old kids
we're just having fun willie and sal
were the kings of cocaine in south
florida they're first generation
immigrants they thought this was their
path to the american dream
the most prolific drug traffickers in
u.s history
[Music]
all of miami considered them local
heroes
because they were like the robin hoods
they always shared their
basically wealth a fortune 500 company
run by a bunch of muchachos
cash boats cars i'm not gonna lie he
wasn't like the first drug dealer that i
went out
the offshore powerboat champions
indicted for trafficking more than 75
tons of cocaine the largest drug case
in history let the games begin and they
did
they enjoyed living on the edge being
like cat and mouse
see if you can find me they would get
arrested just change your id get new
driver's licenses
that's my answer
[Music]
we paid off detectives judge us high
people all the way in the united states
government
did we have sex in jail yes i mean the
whole thing lasted less than 30 seconds
even though everyone believed there was
willian sal orchestrating these murders
there was no evidence to support it so
you're gonna order me kill
now i'm gonna testify are you crazy they
were untouchable
i knew it was a matter of time sal and
willie were going to be caught how many
times can you go into a bullfight and
they'll get hurt
olay this was the best show that miami
has ever seen
as long as they're working together i
don't see any danger in it
[Music]
i want everyone to answer this question
all right i'll give you a second to
think about it
now raise your hand if you think you're
a lucky person
just ramon okay raise your hand if you
think you're unlucky
got it okay and put your hands down what
about you mr corbin
what's that you didn't raise your hand
me uh
no i i mean i feel like a lucky person
[Music]
i'm having anxiety or panic or something
both
yeah what's the difference i'm gonna
need a sub for today what's bothering
you
everything it just feels like i blew the
whole thing like i
suck as a person you're not entitled to
a perfect partner or a perfect life
i didn't leave you because you became a
teacher i left because i thought i was
doing what i love with the man i love
to see me through how was your weekend
it was great there's some big man there
guys
[Music]
all right good morning happy monday
everything is a complete disaster you've
had the privilege of expecting
everything to just work out
now that you're faced with some
adversity
it could feel like the end of the world
you want to stop feeling like you're
feeling
what about this weighted blanket it
costs 250 we can make our own version
you can't
make your own version
[Music]
you feeling less anxious no i'm really
not
you can't stop thinking about all the
things you should have done and why you
didn't do
[Music]
i know i can be negative sometimes it's
not how i want to be
nothing is perfect i don't know why
that's so hard for you to see
the question is what do you do now
[Music]
no one has seen a stolen food truck
would you
full of chips i've never seen anything
like that
[Music]
you're good thieves best in town thank
you
it is a small town
tell your friends i don't have any go
get some then
okay we could be in california as soon
as
two months california here we come
you and your buggy ass friends what are
you going to fight for
ah i just have no idea what what
oh you guys watching this it'll be like
a month
kind of gangers both red and blue indian
mafia couldn't make up their minds if
they want to be bloods or crips more
maybe they're blips or maybe they're
cruds
it's easy to be bad
[Music]
it's hard to be a warrior with dignity
[Music]
the isa are done i've beat grundy
and cindy berman probably got crushed
when the dish caved in
the others could what others court
dragon king is dead
tigers and sports master they're locked
up we're the justice society of america
we can't quit
i've got a responsibility as star girl
to stay vigilant
you got a responsibility at school i
think you're looking for trouble court
you have to decide if putting on that
mask is worth messing up
everything else in your life being a
superhero doesn't mean that the rest of
your life takes a back seat
it's about finding a balance
[Music]
the staff chose me for a reason that
goes beyond the injustice society
who are you
i'm green lantern's daughter
[Music]
there's this villain from the old days
why is he in blue valley
something very bad yeah
we're never gonna stop fighting to
protect the world from people like you
don't you teach these children any
manners
[Music]
star girl new episodes start august 10th
free next day only on the cw app
what the hell are you doing i'm going in
[Music]
look at you welcome to fantasy island
you can't deny it so the island is magic
i transform people's lives
almost always for the better i'm you
love you she faced off dust this isn't
face off she freaking fronted us
every guest thinks they can leave out a
beautiful dream
it's never that simple i know when
you're not telling me the truth
let the adventure begin why did you
bring me here
just know i don't get any pleasure from
this
okay maybe just
space time
time time reality
it's more than a linear path it's a
prism
of endless possibility well that doesn't
sound ominous at all
i was promised an army
you have a super soldier
oh you sure don't seem too freaked out
about all this kid
what you doing out there all by yourself
anyway exploring
the world sounds fun but why stop at one
world
when we can show you all of them
i am the watcher
i am your guide through these vast new
realities
follow me and dare to face the unknown
and ponder the question
what if
give me the tour
i was out here all alone once
bruce made me go out into the forest by
myself for the first time
i had no idea what was out there
he was just a boy those were the lessons
that he taught you
bruce was a psychopath using fear to
control everyone
you need to make sure that this doesn't
happen to someone else
[Music]
that man's ally was found dead tonight
[Music]
it's over for me be a better batman
barbara welcome back to gotham dick
batman's gone gotham
it's mine now we're investigating this
new red hood case
it was he said be a better batman the
titans got this
you know how crazy that is right trying
to step into your father's shoes
i do commissioner gordon
whole world is turned upside down
i think i'm losing my mind if you're
gonna dub
i'm gonna hawk we need to stop it
for cases like these we've been using a
consultant
scarecrow dr crane
dick grayson red hood is a biblical
brother
the king moves stealthily in the shadows
while the ponds are sent to the teeth of
destruction
it's just his opening move
where i come from you come after family
we show no mercy
[Music]
i'm scared that my time with you will be
cut short
no more stakeouts or drinks after a long
shift or midnight calls when you've had
a breakthrough in a case
i've always had this image of us in our
90s hunting down criminals at the
retirement home
but i guess that was just a dumb fantasy
jake are you crying no
yes in the face
of crisis i seem to have sent a digital
phallus
portrait oh no you sent him a pic chaos
the other district sent us their
hitchcock and scully's dear god
nine nine guys and child care
what are you doing here what are you
doing here you're supposed to be getting
mad from daycare
one team will rise this workplace is my
family was that not clear holt is my dad
you're my immune older sister amy's my
mom what what what did i say
for one hot damn last
ride it is as peralta would say
no big hoop but i actually don't
pronounce the h in whoop
let's ride
[Music]
my edibles just kicked in
witness the air oh dear
well it seems i was wrong the hoop
is big after all again though there's
there's no h
in weapon hoop whoop
am i crazy how do you say it it's a loop
okay
brooklyn nine-nine the final season
premieres august 12th on nbc
and watch all past seasons on peacock
[Music]
what was your name katie katie okay i'm
alexa
hey there she is
cheers
so you want me to call you if you want
but i realized i might be coming off
like some kind of gross late night guy
you're not gross
no don't
run from the snow i just spent the night
with the woman of my dreams things are
getting curved
they're good for you where'd you meet i
used to be married to her
why don't you text her i don't have a
number how are you going to contact this
woman we arranged to meet on the train
two weeks from now she's never gonna
show
[Music]
i really just don't want to give you the
wrong idea i don't understand
i really don't want to lead you on it
why did you kiss me
i truly hope you find happiness do you
of course
[Music]
it's my first night out and a lot mine
too sisters
i love you but i miss you
[Music]
love comes in all forms
[Music]
the whole world exists just for you
it's a fairy tale
how does it end
[Music]
your dad built a cathedral
to a local pastime what are you trying
to resurrect here anyway
[Music]
people need to believe that we can be
better
your washed up quarterback couldn't play
in college
i'm a lawnmower salesman it is not
enough for me
brother's sparring
dale's oldest time people only love the
good guys
as much as they hate the bad
wrestlers it is who we are
[Music]
you're here for the 10-day retreat us
2.0
i certainly am apparently i'm
in need of some fixing
welcome to tranquillium house
the people who come here they come to
heal
i don't want to suffer you're already
suffering
[Music]
breakfast seven lunch noon dinner 7 30.
and how many guests are there nine total
wellness retreats is such utter crap and
yet here you are
all right let's go meditate
i want you all now to close your eyes
you wanna get well you wanna heal
surrender yourself to me
i am gonna fix you
so what's your story i have one
everybody has a story
that's right pictures what do you mean
she picked us
we complement each other's demons
i'm not sure i'm really supposed to be
here
my vote is give this thing a shot open
up a new door
some doors are meant to stay closed
yeah it could be a real [ __ ] show what
the hell do i know right
this is a particularly volatile group
let's start the protocol
i don't think they're ready
it's perfectly safe i've been feeling
unlike myself
the wheels starting to fall
she picked nine people who needed to be
in a place where they would try
anything she wanted have you all gone
mad
[Music]
there's nothing to fear
because this
it's gonna change
[Music]
you have to go to work i can hear you
we are a cbd store please don't tell our
customers to smoke weed
don't do that no i'm gonna do that
beginning
[Applause]
i got next i've been going out with
brenda for a while now
this could be serious was it what do you
mean getting serious serious serious
oh oh oh my god
i can't leave your room without catching
hep c
oh somebody's gonna be late again
hey that's my underwear we're wearing
grandma's underwear no i'm not wearing
girls underwear these are my underwears
i bought these in the 99 cent store
we'll be talking about like non-profit
work charity work
acting los angeles
[Music]
we're concerned about what's going on in
the department
this is already all over social media
this department's hanging on by a threat
bill's incident spinning out of control
oh there she is our first lady chair
woman
i'm not going to sugarcoat this we're in
dire crisis
i wouldn't be surprised if the president
asked for bill's resignation
can he stay for dinner no no wonder
nobody wanted to marry you
are you too involved my defending
professor dobson has nothing to do with
my feelings for him
which are entirely platonic and
professional everybody knows she's in
love with her
you're wearing makeup what no it's
pretty
don't you ever think about it
when i see something i wish i had shut
up
treasure dobson i just like him he's
smart
and hot don't take your jacket off i
don't know how to say this so i'm just
gonna say
it get your [ __ ] together i like when
you act like you're my boss
i am your boss this has become
a serious reputational matter oh god
sorry i thought you were naked you
should be running this place instead
you're running around playing nice
i feel like someone handed me a ticking
time bomb because they wanted to make
sure a woman was holding him when it
explodes
nobody wants to come out and support you
when you're a scandalous figure
your boy's toast tell me what to do
you're going to apologize
i'm so sorry i oh my god not to me
dumbass
i am the chair of the department let's
[ __ ] shake this place up
what is it bad memories
of what
alexandra's our home
what we have it's rare
if we live we live for them
we gotta get through this together
if we die we die for them
do you want to talk about it
we need to start thinking about other
options
alexandria needs us
it's everything we have
so you're leaving to fight ghosts
this is a path you don't want to go down
i've done worse
these people they want stuff
[Applause]
that is what's out there
don't be scared i'm not
god isn't here anymore
this is a death march
and you are the damn pied piper the
paranoid
but i'm right
i lost something and i don't think it's
a bad thing that it did
i did what needed to be done you
destroyed everything that we built
the only way this works is if we trust
each other
so what do you say
if you say trust him i'll trust him
the woman who lift is not the one
standing here now
so keep pushing me please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello i'm lance hornsby welcome
to the commonwealth
uh
um
captain dear cousin charles
by the time you receive this letter i
shall be in my final resting place
i bequeath you a magnificent ancestral
home we call
chapel wait what do you think
[Music]
hardly know what to say myself
i hear you're looking for a governess
yeah
your family has a reputation children
are they christian some blame chapel
wait for the illness in town
the bones are surrounded by misfortune
father
are we safe here
once the people see that there's nothing
to fear this animosity will diminish
unless there is something to fear
i see things things that aren't real
your feelings weren't my feelings for
all of them
bad things are coming all that you
believe is madness
that is my curse
only i can save you
i would rather die than to risk hurting
my family
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
my tactics were flawless and yet my
forces lie decimated because you left
your beastman exposed to his chaos dwarf
prepare
nave to call me knave again
oh hello there you're probably wondering
what we're doing short answer
saving the earth again
okay we'll pull out here phrasing
phrasing it's time
for a page
it's a play on words pam and rampage fan
page
climate change is a threatening problem
i recycle
three dollar ties from goodwill don't
count
that's the second biggest automatic loop
wall i've ever seen
helicopter i'm not leaving without you
cyril
i need something soft to land on
what's with all these overly decorative
pests you mean butterflies kill them as
caterpillars i say
a fearless warrior in a world without
sight
everyone close to you always ends up
suffering
[Music]
now it's your turn brother
i swore i would never return here but
you know took my daughter
[Music]
i need to find out where he's hiding
here
[Music]
a shift in the world
we are chosen to usher in a new world
i carry within me a child born with
god's gift
of vision
[Applause]
sight will return and the first nation
to harness its powers
will dominate the world
you're declaring war on the greatest
military force in the world
this is not our fight if we walk away
thousands of people will die
i know this enemy i was this enemy
they fight to enslave we fight for
freedom
i say we open our gate right now
and welcome them to hell
[Applause]
[Music]
there are weapons more powerful
they look the key to our future
[Music]
welcome home bubba
[Music]
this doesn't make sense where do we
start
at the very beginning i got in the
elevator with these two weirdos
then tim got in the elevator
approximately 12 minutes from now i will
be murdered
tim cono's death has been ruled a
homicide
and apparently one of you jerk-offs did
it
i can't stop thinking about them neither
can i we should do our own true crime
podcast
we're gonna go down there and look
around for clues you wanna come
do i wanna break into a dead guy's
apartment and go through all his [ __ ]
sounds like an afternoon
right now the only thing that matters is
that there's a killer on the loose in
our building
oh that is a very good line badly
delivered but a good line
i think we're on to something big here
and these are
candid photos i took of our neighbors
why are they all selfies so i don't draw
suspicion
it's so hot in here do we have to do
this in a closet the acoustics are
better and trust me you need acoustics
i'm gonna pass out
get the who the how the why and the wine
out get the what or the what
see why would you say what i never said
what there's no what
[ __ ] just got super real
i think our list of suspects just got
longer
hold on
get out of the building now exclamation
point exclamation point
oh my god
keep your eyes peeled anything can be a
clue
there's a very strong chance the killer
is musical superstar sting
the guy from you too
do you consent to being recorded just
say anything to agree
no please thanks perfect
we're gonna cut um i like the emotion
keep that
i kind of need you to enunciate better
do you have anything
the crying is covering the dialogue oh
that's a good that's a good name okay
when you're ready and action
you